golpe para los defensores del control de
armas el tribunal supremo de eeuu anuló
una ley que prohibía el porte de armas
en público en el estado de nueva york-
ampliando así el derecho de los
estadounidenses a salir a armados de sus
casas la asociación nacional de rifle el
poderoso lobby de armas celebró la
decisión victoria de la asociación
nacional del rifle el tribunal supremo
afirmó que el derecho a portar armas no
se detiene en la puerta de la casa de
una persona mientras que el clan
democrático no tardó en reaccionar
condenado firmemente el fallo entiende
todo el mundo lo que significa un arma
oculta
significa que no tienen ninguna
previsión de que alguien puede esconder
un arma y entrar en nuestro metro en
nuestras tiendas como las de búfalo
donde yo vivo la asociación nacional del
rifle defiende una lectura literal de la
segunda enmienda de la constitución de
eeuu que establece el derecho del pueblo
a portar armas en
1939 el tribunal supremo limitó esta
legislación a las fuerzas del orden pero
cambió su posición en 2008 cuando
estableció el derecho a postear un arma
en el hogar sin embargo dejó en manos de
los estados la regulación del porte
fuera de casa la sentencia de este
jueves pone fin a esta flexibilidad y
fija en piedra el derecho a portar armas
el presidente joe biden se dijo
decepcionado el tribunal supremo de eeuu
ha optado por anular una autoridad
establecida desde hace tiempo por nueva
york para proteger a sus ciudadanos este
fallo contradice tanto el sentido común
como la constitución y debería
preocuparnos profundamente a todos la
decisión tomada por una mayoría de seis
de los nueve jueces todos conservadores
se produce cuando el país sigue
conmocionado por una serie de tiroteos
incluido uno el 24 de mayo que dejó 19
niños de primaria y 2 profesoras muertos
en una escuela primaria de texas